garçon quelle Chine improbable qui je suis tu
ne semblais pas avoir de problème quand il a
été jeté de la force
il était le défi du roi il a perdu tu
voulais qu'il perde il n'était pas apte à
diriger le Chara m'a dit en face
ici  si vous ramenez l'a-t-il fait il l'a
eu le Joker l'a volé à notre je
m'en
fous de nous il a épousé ma mère
et mon père trente ans il n'y a pas eu de
justice et T Challa a juré de le
ramener pas emmené au  L'ONU n'est pas emmenée à
l'IC à ras bord nous a frappé
c'est ce que vous voudriez que je laisse la
porte ou pour amener nos enfants dans
ce monde où ils deviennent des conquérants
oui que les enfants seront les leaders d'un
monde vraiment libre pas seulement un petit pays
où nous devons cacher tout ce qui
fait de nous de grands euros dans la guerre et la mort mais
à la fin ce sera beau
et Wakanda se tiendra debout
vous